[Music]
Well, I think it will leave a very strong legacy,
not for the country and for the region.
I think it's also very good that
Arab culture is made known. I think
there is a great prejudice, there has been a
lot of criticism of Arab culture.
People are seeing what Qatar
is and what it is not, the unfair criticism
they are receiving and I think that people
will take very good memories of the country
[Music]
Well so far there have been many
surprises, not Japan itself, the
Saudi miss wonder  I was also
surprised I knew them from here in Asia
to also know Qatar it was a
shame to accept that they have not competed well at
their level but you will be seeing a surprise
it is difficult to predict something no
[Applause]